this is the very first third-party  magsafe puck on the market that actually  charges at 15 watts just like apple's  original max save charger and i believe  that there are multiple reasons why you  should buy this one instead we have this  nice raided cable that looks really good  this cable is twice as long as apple  definitely no weaker and i would say it  is a little bit stronger as far as  magnets and that makes sense because it  is thicker let's talk about a few  downsides it does not come with a  charging adapter in the box you will not  be able to use one of the many  third-party accessories that have been  created for apple's pucks costs more  money but you are getting a quality  product with extra features for that  price let me go ahead and go and do some  testing and we'll see just how fast  belkin's option is the belkin charger is  faster and it charges 30 minutes faster  than apple's puck